[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
it has been a huge honor to be prime
minister of this great country
in particular to lead the nation in
mourning the death of her late Majesty
the queen after 70 years of service and
welcoming the accession of his majesty
King Charles III
in just a short period this government
has acted urgently and decisively on the
side of hard-working families and
businesses
we reversed the National Insurance
increase we helped millions of
households with their energy bills and
help thousands of businesses avoid
bankruptcy
we are taking back our energy
Independence so we are never again
beholden to Global Market fluctuations
or malign foreign powers
from my time as prime minister I am more
convinced than ever that we need to be
bold and confront the challenges that we
face
as the Roman philosopher Seneca wrote
it's not because things are difficult
that we do not dare it's because we do
not dare that they are difficult
we simply cannot afford to be a
low-growth country where the government
takes up an increasing share of our
national wealth and where there are huge
divides between different parts of our
country
we need to take advantage of our brexit
freedoms to do things differently
this means delivering more freedom for
our own citizens and restoring power to
democratic institutions
it means lower taxes so people can keep
more of the money that they earn
and it means delivering growth that will
lead to more job security higher wages
and greater opportunities for our
children and grandchildren
democracies must be able to deliver for
their own people
we must be able to out-compete
autocratic regimes where power lies in
the hands of a few
and now more than ever we must support
Ukraine in their Brave fight against
Putin's aggression
Ukraine must prevail
and we must continue to strengthen our
nation's defenses
that's what I have been striving to
achieve and I wish Rishi sunak every
success for the good of our country
I want to thank you Francis Liberty my
family and friends and all the team at
number 10 for their love friendship and
support
I also want to thank my Protection Team
I look forward to spending more time in
my constituency and continuing to serve
Southwest Norfolk from the back benches
our country continues to battle Through
Your Storm
but I believe in Britain
I believe in the British people
and I know that brighter days lie ahead
thank you
[Applause]
the short speech she now walks off the
waiting car with her husband followed by
her two daughters and really a speech
sticking to her message focusing on
growth focusing on low tax talking about
it is because we do not dare to do do
things that things are
difficult